[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado al día
hablamos de los galardonados o con el
premio Nobel de paz 2022 el comité Nobel
noruego con senos los se lo otorgó a la
bielo ruso Alex vialinsky y a las
organizaciones Memorial de Rusia y a la
ucraniana centers
por su lucha por el derecho a criticar
El Poder y denunciar crímenes contra la
humanidad saludamos a Diego Osorio
experto en seguridad climática y en
proyectos de solución de conflictos a
nivel mundial Diego Gracias por estar
con nosotros esta mañana de viernes en
directo América de Franz 24 se otorgaron
entonces en los premios el premio Nobel
de paz a estas a 13 personas pues una
persona y dos organizaciones en este
contexto mundial de guerra que
representa este premio Nobel
bueno ante todo Muchísimas gracias por
esta oportunidad de hablar con todos
ustedes esto representa sobre todo un
gran voto de confianza y un y un gran
estímulo a lo que es la fuerza y la
necesidad de una sociedad civil robusta
entendamos Que los tres premios lleva
los los tres galardonados
combinan en sí diferentes elementos de
lo que es esa sociedad la capacidad de
hablar de decir las cosas de llevarla de
llevar la verdad de buscar y mantener la
verdad no solamente en el presente pero
también en el pasado como lo hace la ong
de memoria y de ser capaz de de hacerle
frente a lo que es un poco el abuso
autoritario de la autoridad no tenemos
que saber que en toda democracia o en
todo en todo sistema de gobierno el
centro es el poder democrático y en el
caso de Bielorrusia pues claramente
estamos frente a una situación que no lo
representa así Entonces es un voto
grande por la sociedad civil y Y eso es
de mucha importancia porque no solamente
tiene una relevancia para la situación
en Ucrania en Bielorrusia y en Rusia
sino para la sociedad civil a nivel
mundial Diego hablemos un poco de
Estados o 13 premiados no primero
empecemos con el bielorruso vale
tíalinsky que fue uno de los fundadores
del movimiento democrático en la década
mediados de la década de 1980 y ahí cao
su vida no va a promover la democracia y
el desarrollo Pacífico en su país que
aporte se ha hecho bialitzky en toda su
lucha actualmente encarcelado
Bueno una cosa muy importante es que en
estos momentos el premio Nobel se
transforma en un gran espaldarazo para
este
activista político porque está en
prisión está en ese momento sufriendo
las los rigores del modo autoritario de
este tipo de regímenes que en el caso de
Bielorrusia es más o menos una copia
exacta de lo que se podía esperar
incluso servicio secreto en Bielorrusia
se llama todavía la caja bebé de lo que
podemos esperar Es decir de lo peor de
sistemas soviético de antaño Entonces el
premio Nobel para él es un espaldarazo
en el sentido de que su labor no es
no está olvidada no es invisible que
todos sabemos que está ahí que todos
sabemos que está luchando por la
libertad y Esperamos que este Premio
Nobel sea verdaderamente un gran apoyo
no solamente para
para amplificar su labor sino también
para lograr o facilitar su proceso de
Liberación en el caso de memoria la
organización rusa si me permite Quisiera
decir algo Bastante importante que es el
hecho de que en el caso de esta
organización en Rusia han querido
reescribir la historia una de las
labores esenciales era que llevaba un
récord histórico de todo lo que había
pasado durante la época soviética
incluyendo el caso de stalin uno de los
allegados a Putin que es ahorita
supuestamente el negociador en jefe del
proceso en Ucrania a lideró un proceso
de reescritura a la historia que es un
procesador veliano y Memorial fue
básicamente clausurada hecho entonces
mantener la verdad pese a todas las
acciones de un gobierno autoritario es
de Gran valor y en el caso de la
organización ucraniana si usted me
permite no solamente es importante
porque está en Ucrania facilita
la articulación de la sociedad civil
sino que también guarda un espíritu
crítico con respecto al gobierno
necraniano es se basa se enfoca y
trabaja sobre la denuncia y la
transparencia la necesidad de de
verdaderamente llevar sobre la mesa la
posibilidad de trabajar sobre lo que es
la corrupción y aún en el caso de lo que
ahorita consideramos un líder bastante
favorecido por el oeste por el occidente
por todas las democracias en la lucha
contra esta invasión de la Unión de
Rusia Pues los casos de corrupción los
pone por delante los hace ver y es
bastante crítica en varios aspectos en
eso guarda un punto bastante balanceado
y me parece que es importante saber que
aún en las situaciones de guerra aún
cuando hay cierto elemento patriótico es
importante valorar la transparencia y la
libertad Diego lo estábamos hablando con
nuestra periodista Marta Moya que
preside el espacio antes de iniciar esta
conversación con usted y es que digamos
estos ganadores el premio Nobel de paz y
luego de recibir el galón son aún más
perseguidos por los gobiernos y por la
gente que no está de acuerdo con el
trabajo con él que no le interesa Mejor
dicho el trabajo que están haciendo por
la pasa por la humanidad se podría haber
un incremento una represión contra Pues
el bielorruso y estas dos ongs por parte
de las personas que no les interesa que
hagan su trabajo
Bueno lo que pasa es que también tenemos
que tomar en cuenta que hay dos
diferentes líneas de tiempo aquí sí
aquellos que buscan la opresión se
enfocan en el corto plazo aquellos que
buscan la libertad lo buscan para al
largo plazo y para que sea estable y
permanente entonces claramente aquellos
que se ven acorralados porque están
básicamente ejerciendo diferentes
niveles de de autoritarismo y de
opresión contra sus pueblos contra la
sociedad civil van a reaccionar con el
único elemento que tienen que es el
elemento de la violencia el elemento de
la acción negativa a largo plazo sí es
cierto que esto puede complicar la
situación de los que están en prisión de
los que están en una situación de
discriminación pero el espaldarazo el
apoyo y el mensaje que envía el la
comunidad global es importante yo creo
que eso es es necesario y no sería una
razón para hacerlo de otra manera el
hecho de que existieran este tipo de
represalias a corto plazo porque si no
pues estaríamos de manos de aquellos que
parte de la libertad Diego antes de
despedirlo Quiero hacerle una Una última
pregunta usted que es experto en el
proyecto de solución de conflictos a
nivel mundial como ve una posible
resolución del conflicto actual en
Ucrania
en el caso de Ucrania yo creo que todos
los conflictos tienen un momento y un y
una oportunidad única para para
resolución para para negociación para
diálogo yo no creo que este sea todavía
el momento para un diálogo es necesario
es importante porque este conflicto
tiene repercusiones de carácter global
pero al mismo tiempo yo creo que las dos
partes están en una lógica de
de cuando la persona cree que puede
ganar trata de doblar en en el proceso
de conflicto yo no creo que estamos al
punto de diálogo desgraciadamente y creo
que esto nos va a llevar al año